come down to show you this is Berlin a
pounding heartbeat growing out as a
divided nation people come to Berlin to
dream
they and to follow
would it be possible to take you to
dinner see I don't speak German what's
this this is nazar is he from the
shelter no I picked him up in an
alleyway I tell you you might be somehow
off my first boyfriend
he was also bit nerdy what would you say
your odds are right about now 5050 5050
this is everything always comes down to
50/50 something's really gonna happen
it's not
[Music]
okay I just had that fight with my
boyfriend I think those kind of things
happen I know what you're doing here is
very noble it's an escape it is not an
escape this is Berlin this is what life
is right now you could have some fun why
what's so important about me going out
the thought of you going out maybe
meeting someone's bloody marvelous
I came here to fly away
I came to restore my face
came to berlin boro rebirth you will
make 5050 brother this is how it all
begins to camp the only love is possible
and I'm proud of you everything is
possible
is this typical Berlin
thanks typical them
you